what y'all's go-to category on the Hub
whoa hey yo the go-to category is it
BBWs
YouTube I'm saying I'll be bumping my
music in the morning Marvin Gaye okay
pause
hey yeah yeah I'm like yo oh [__] me I'm
afrido what's your go-to uh category
[__] I got my own personal archive oh
you got your you just you're just
digging through the memories I'm a
director myself
you know so you you're only going off of
your own personal material I'm just
making quality material
are you ever afraid that kind of [__]
can leak
I'll be hoping my [__] going it's the
thing like
no I actually I need some [__] to leave
because I did some goofy [__] like
nah for real cause I [__] like I was
trying to show my tattoo one time like
like a couple years back I just got a
tattoo on my stomach boom I was like in
the bathroom just making a video like
this boom
and I actually like you showed your dick
yeah it was like from a weird angle like
from the top and it wasn't it wasn't
flattering man it was like it's like it
was like right in between like the hose
like we can't tell if it's long or short
like
yeah I did it on purpose trust me I
would he looked at that video he said
that's the one if I'm gonna show my [__]
on the ground you think I'm gonna show
it like that hell no I'm gonna show that
[__] in there
accidentally showed everybody your dick
man I'm in the Hills I'm in the Airbnb
just got the tattoo boom
this one the Instagram just changed but
once I'm in the bathroom I'm getting
ready to go somewhere I'm in the
bathroom
I accidentally hit the it's a button
where you don't even it don't even ask
you do you want to post this yeah yeah
it just goes to your story right
okay Mom I think that's my phone up I
actually hit that button boom so boom
upload to my story so I'm getting ready
still just trying to shout out for my
clothes on this [__] on this [__] online
circling circulating online you know you
check your phone you're like oh [__] I'm
just doing my normal activities getting
dressed with my kids I'm going to the
car so it's like a 15-20 minute process
of just me going from the bathroom to
the car driving drive around the hills
you know what I'm saying no service on
my phone no idea what's happening no
idea what's going underwear so Boom
everybody start hitting me sway dick is
online I'm like what like boom because I
did right before that though while I was
getting a tattoo I'm uploading all type
of [__] my drawers right here yeah you
can see it right my midsection yeah so
like look I was like oh they talking
about yeah because I did that make
session on this [__] I did post
purposely right so then boom like what
boom like stop playing and watch my
story everyone okay see that boom cool
boom still driving somebody else hit me
sway bro check your Gram your meat is
online I'm like what the [__]
make sure there was no meat on it
it's like 10 minutes later yeah my [__]
was on there like but it was late at
night so boom I Knew by morning like man
this [__] it was everywhere yeah I knew
it was gonna be fired by tomorrow so at
that point if it's an um unflattering
angle of your dick do you say hit one of
the Shorties and be like yo I'm gonna
need you to just throw it out I'm like
man we gotta shows
you just gotta drop another
meat pick no no no no for sure you gotta
drop another one you just gotta go back
to back with them yeah like definitely
one day I'm gonna have to because like
some people still be like you know what
I'm saying sometimes trolling and [__]
like you know hey some people are
[__] know [__] know like
Growers are not showers
have you ever accidentally leaked photos
of your dick no but look I'm trying to
figure out how to accidentally do it
if anybody got any tips it's really easy
it's super easy what's the correct way
you know what I'm saying it's no correct
way
only fans in it you do yeah stay off the
only fans guys